hello and welcome to a very special now
playing of quantum break we are the time
wizards daniel dwyer michael mccarty how
you doing mike good how are you i'm
great i've played a bunch of this game
over the past week or so we got it super
early this thing's not there for like
three weeks right uh but uh we're not
let's show a lot of the game for a lot
of that show all the game world i'd show
a
snippet of the game which is about i'll
say
30 minutes in maybe after a big event
okay and then we have to stop it short
of the second half uh the second chapter
uh which is fine because there's a big
massive tv show in the middle of us
which we may or may not watch okay which
uh which will be changed uh slightly
based on the decisions that we make so
uh let's let's hop right into it i'm
gonna be playing you are going to be
uh checking out the twitch chat
primarily right and we join our heroes
mr uh jack joyce played by sean ashmore
iceman and mr william joyce they buy
dominic monaghan one of those hobbits
that was the first time my power started
to manifest and that was the first time
his powers started to manifest
so
this is our boy look doesn't he look
very photorealistic
yeah you're already in an area that
looks like it would be the end of any
other game right yeah yeah this is the
start of the game
some embargoed stuff happened up there
which was on that show a university and
uh and right now we're trying to escape
from the uh the horrible events that
have happened i just killed this guy
with time powers and you'll see a bit
more of that in a second okay now i got
a pistol so this is a straight up
third-person shooter
it's in the guys of alan wake and max
payne before us remedy know how to make
third-person shooters
but this one is a lot more
narrative driven there's a lot of
exploration environmental storytelling
picking up things some of those things
matter some of them don't there's a lot
of reading
there's a lot of you know picking up
pieces of articles of uh
from newspapers and whatnot and and
reading it if you want to and then
there's other stuff which is
essentially
uh objects that when you pick them up
they change the narrative of the game
okay but how much they do that is really
sort of
because uh i haven't really come across
yet because i'm not too too far but
halfway through the game do they like
cause disturbances in the time space
continuum or whatever doc brown always
says not really like you're not the game
is very linear than what i've played it
is very
linear set piece orientated i would say
as well okay especially this first part
so this part here is you know we're
still in storytelling mode so they're
not really uh they're not really
allowing you to have much agency here
whatsoever right but i do get to press l
to move forward it's nice so there's
that
following mary through the yes
tunnels and what exactly yeah we're
going to keep an eye on the twitch chat
as well let us know if the audio sounds
all good and whatnot obviously we're
talking over some very good hollywood
actors here so
yeah let us know oh we would we better
be quiet
okay we're good we're good i gotta press
l to move forward some more mike
causing tension tension it's not really
tense for me because i've already done
this yeah but
you're also having a casual conversation
with this guy
my hobbit brother yeah
just hit the wall
that's pretty good actually
so so i will say the acting and
and and some of this uh some of the the
writing is actually pretty pretty good
it's pretty it's pretty pretty sharp
they want a bit more audio
yeah there you go
let me know if that's better i turn it
up a little bit
uh we also have littlefinger from game
of thrones in this as well who is trying
very very hard
aidan gillan to uh hide his northern
irish accent but it doesn't really do a
very good job
this is bigger than us he had the worst
boston accent ever in the wire
trying to kill him
speaking of the wire lance reddick from
the wire is also in this as well
he'll come up later on involved is the
last thing i wanted
i'm sorry so essentially right
the game over the course of the first
chapter is introducing you to your
various time wizard powers so there are
powers such as
stop time in a bubble
and
bubble of
time shield that'll protect you from
bullets
and
running fast because of time and
essentially once they layer a couple of
these on it makes the combat uh
interesting
what i will say is from from from
playing and i'm not reviewing it or
anything like that peter brands are
doing this game but from playing it
i think coming off the division
i've i've felt like the like the
movement and the shooting in this is way
more floaty than i'd like okay
which you're about to see in a second
all right get down i gotta shoot this
guy
so right now it's
oh and they also totally stole the
slow-mo from max payne three okay which
is beautiful because they made the
original max payne and then rockstar
made max payne three so i think that's
that's actually pretty cool just taking
it back yeah they're just like [ __ ]
we're going to take your cool slow down
mechanic oh no get down get done
so you snap to cover
so i just pressed a there because i was
maybe the game played down a little bit
probably yeah yeah because uh
i've been playing a lot of the division
recently lately so if i if i pop up here
it's gonna see like the decent amount of
auto targeting which you can turn off if
you want i can't just throw a chair at
me
i'm shooting the chair
yeah he's trying he's trying to shoot
chairs at me
there is a lot of that actually a lot of
physics wobbliness look
kick bodies around and stuff this is on
xbox one yes we're playing on xbox one
right now there is a pc version which
tough spots and we'll be coming out on
windows 10
which is now a thing we have to worry
about
the game is not coming out on steam so
uh user desart was asking from what you
play and what you can talk about does
this feel like a sam lake game like from
what you play yeah it feels super remedy
which you know
which which means i think kind of means
two things one there's a very specific
type of movement that happens in these
games and this this feels like that okay
uh
two it means that it's it feels
relatively linear like very linear like
alan wake was linear as hell right and
it didn't suffer because of it like it
was a
game that was telling a particular story
and it had particular set pieces and
through the sort of linear oh yeah
murder him boom boom pulled you through
at a good pace
yeah it and what it does is it allows
them to set up interesting set pieces as
well right
like and like this game has a lot of
like wow kind of slow down moments
happening i haven't been using my powers
at all so i should probably start to do
that yeah show us some uh some time
powers yeah i think i've only got one at
the moment so i'm going to have to
and sadly i just went over the tutorial
where it was is it called bullet time no
it's
flip off rocks oh look i picked up a
narrative object all right
so you can there's a lot of these
there's a lot of emails have you read
through any of these extensively or i
have until i realized just how many are
in this game yeah and then i was like
i'll screw it out it's going to mess up
these chairs though i always feel bad
because i know there was like someone
who went through a lot to write those
but
when they're just thrown at you left and
right it's kind of tough to
i'd rather play a game i mean there's a
reason why audio logs exist right
because they you get to the best of both
worlds i need look at this guy we need
to get to my car so the acting is super
good
the story is interesting because it's
doing that whole
you know what happened first thing
where you're like
this is the start of the story for me
but how much of the story has been
played out already at this stage sure
like how there are people from the
future people from the past
versions of other people who are from
maybe the doors you know from the
timeline you know them and then the
timeline 17 years ahead like it's it's
it's kind of all over the place which is
which is cool it makes it makes it
interesting drops you in what's the term
in media arrests or whatever in the
middle of the story kind of yeah
whoa
i use my time wizard powers
did he do that on accident trigger it i
think so a harry potter thing yeah he is
yes he is discovering his powers
you might want to help him get those
bullets
press y to save brother from bullets
pull them out
somehow i could focus and unfreeze will
even if the world was still frozen so
this is cool right look at that look how
rad that looks yeah and this happens a
lot and i like it a lot
about the fracture can i walk through
these bullets yeah you know what the
best thing i can do is
take this guy's gun oh that's great
they're they're like their magazines are
full of tracer rounds it looks like it
makes sense for
it looks better when it's paused
internal combat yeah really need to know
where your bullets are going yeah uh
yeah i don't think i even need those
bullets
yeah so this is you know
the start of the game
this is where you came in earlier so
this is like a
you know what it was like before you
came in there was like student protests
happening in here so now
naturally there's some police clamping
down on some students look at that [ __ ]
though look at that
this is a girl
who you were talking who you can choose
to talk to earlier in the game as well
she may or may not have a part in the
story depending on your your actions
okay
he's out trying to pull her out of oh
that's true my time wizard powers aren't
working
look at that thing i don't even know
what that is
it looks really good they talk a lot
about chronons which are the
time
mcguffin
sort of powers a lot of what's what's
going on in this uh like the m word from
the early star wars movies yes okay is
the are the metaphorians of
so later on there are like
big tubs of cronons that you can shoot
and make
time stuff happen
yeah but we're gonna see a lot more of
the the time combat coming up in the
next section here okay
any more questions from yeah can you
talk about the relationship between the
tv show the tv episodes and
like tv gameplans and it sounded like
what they were going to do was have the
tv show run alongside this because the
tv show kind of tells a separate
perspective
so this is this guy's perspective right
but then monarch who's the company who's
doing all the time nonsense the tv show
kind of focuses on what's happening
there along
you know along the same time as what's
happening here
so
previously they had this tv show running
literally around the same time or you
know on television but now it just
happens
after each chapter so once i'm done with
this chapter there will be a 20
odd minute television show like really
well produced like shockingly well
produced uh
way better than it should be like really
like i'm a you know cameron camera nerd
in the director you know fanboy whatever
but like like i
so i i really like how well it shot and
then clearly they spent a lot of money
on it does it almost approach being
better than the gameplay at any point uh
no i think they're actually a pretty
good match and it has a lot of the same
characters in both which is pretty cool
i mean i haven't played enough of that
stuff to really give an opinion on it
and i'm not reviewing the game either so
i mean we're still under embargo for
some of that stuff but like it i was
surprised by how good it was okay
uh well i i think my expectations were
probably a bit lower
you've also got batman vision
oh okay
because video games yeah see that goes
from the only the flip side of that is i
almost spend the entire game in like
especially in batman or far cry primal
in that detective mode kind of like i
feel like i'm missing out if i'm not
yeah i'm curious once like once you play
the entire game what you think of like
the pacing as far as how playing a
chapter than the tv show and then
playing a chapter like how that affects
the pacing i mean i only did it once so
i can't tell how how much it really
affects it but
yeah i'm gonna murder these guys though
because that's fun
this video game murders
is where it's at
i don't know if this guy's got any i
think he does i think his backstory has
some sort of like
murder training
boom best part of the game
uh any more questions from our chitty
chat friends um while i pick up all
these dead gentlemen's guns is this
single player only
yes i do not believe there's any
multiplayer i'm pretty sure there's no
multiplayer i am
positive
so yeah this is just single player and
xbox one for those asking about the
platform as well
of the past um
i'm gonna read this echo arriving at the
university which is not at all
dissimilar from the division
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna check check his gun or his car
that's not a gun that's a car
watch out
whoa better use my time powers all right
boom
something clicked here we are time
bubble yeah this is the fun one and stop
time in a focused area
so you don't have to use your a lot of
your powers at the start because they're
just teaching you how to do it but this
is when it sort of kicks in
so i'm going to use
do you know if you can play this
basically pump a bunch of guns bullets
into them and it's done uh play it
offline they're like is this someone's
asking if this isn't always online no no
no no no this is just a single player
game i mean you know you want your cloud
saves you swapping consoles make sure
you do that but otherwise you just make
a time bubble and then shoot it full of
bullets
and then all the bullets to the guy at
the same time which is pretty cool
cool
slow down right on the edge and then
just
pummel him exactly a shotgun or
something one goat yeah
again the stuff like pretty easy it's
pretty forgiving yeah
i've run into bullets though so it's
gonna be a problem
oh thank you son of a [ __ ]
does it feel like a lot of the powers
have like quick time events attached to
them or still feel like it's like third
person combat throughout no this feels
this feels pretty combat the thing that
took a little while to get used to was
the
the movement and
and the the aiming as well because it's
a little bit on the
i don't know is it sluggish or something
there's a weight to the character which
kind of throws me off a bit okay
kind of like the last of us at the
beginning starts off with that yeah i
mean you kind of acclimatized to it i
think at the start it bothered me more
than it does than it does now because i
played so much but
yeah certain games always have that
weight to the weapons like battlefield
and killzone always have them whereas
you know call of duty just like this
twitch like as if it's part of your arm
yeah killzone is a really good delta for
this actually a good comparison
and that you kind of get used to it
after a while maybe gta 4 in that it
feels very imprecise sure gta 4 felt
like like five felt a lot more
like you're in control of where you were
shooting whereas four felt a bit more
imprecise and that's kind of where this
is right
boom
look at that
look at that time murder
oh and his shotgun blast came a little
bit late that was pretty cool
uh let me see if there's no it's not i
thought there was maybe there's one
power that i've skipped actually when i
was doing this
so
yeah shield is the bob big bubble um
which i don't think i've i've unlocked
yet
shield
yeah so that's the other thing is that
you do a bizarre amount of platforming
in this game yeah that's what i had been
hearing
is it
have you done something yeah so they
have like
tomb raider style environmental
where's my brother ooh
that was good acting hardcore acting
there sir
uh yeah where you're trying to like
you know get on top of a roof or get in
a window and you have to you know scale
the buildings but oh here's this part
that broke down so i'm going to use my
time power to reverse time to make the
building go back together and then walk
over the top so look i don't know if you
can make it but there's a bunch of that
and it seems
relatively interesting from what i've
tried so far but again i'm pretty early
the first time you saw beth wilder yeah
it's odd yeah watching trailers and
everything before this we had gotten the
chance to play this i never really
considered the fact there would be a lot
of platforming yeah or any or any right
yeah exactly i mean there was kind of a
little bit of
maybe not platforming but like
puzzles within the game world in uh in
alan wake as well like light puzzles and
things
sure and so what's happening now is that
you know the the story is being told via
a interview that's happening sometime in
the future okay so that's why he
she the lady who's interviewing just
said that's the first time you met beth
wilder
nothing wilder i think that's her name
maybe i just made that up time echoes
that's also a thing
no time to lose no time to lose here no
time to lose there's lots of time funds
in this game
that's what i was hoping for
look at this guy we're made of voxels
yeah i was going to say
what sorry what was the unit the
crotons croutons croutons cronons
pronons are they
triangular in shape is that what we're
seeing them i don't know maybe and
they're blurs
maybe
who knows
is this the door i'm supposed to go ash
or did i just oh no i walked in here by
accident i don't think i'm supposed to
go here so does each time power have
individual cooldown or are they all on
the same like meters yes they do see
that thing on the right side sure so
that's
boom okay see there yeah
go inside and go into time that's what i
want look at that whoa that really
messed up my head a bit
freeze burst but i'm pretty sure i'm
supposed to go at the store it's on the
chalkboard if i press up
it'll tell me where i want to go
which apparent oh it's up there
ah very good okay wrong door
before it's too late that's how video
games work not like real life the place
you oh hey what's up guys oh this is
whoa
lb to time dodge
so all these powers as well you can
upgrade
based on finding
these like random chronon packages
around the game world okay
which uh which i might see in a second i
can also then
dive through the air like or jump
through the time like that [ __ ] and if i
do it right
oh
yeah all right get out of jail free card
there murder that guy uh the
destructibility of the the environment
is actually super cool it's gonna say
that bookshelf just collapsed see we
have to slow down time there as well so
if i do the the jump forward dash and
then hold left trigger straight away it
slows down time for like a bit of a
second which is pretty cool i'm curious
how much the branching choices and
whatnot will affect maybe any
replayability this game has or doesn't
have yeah they they were saying that you
should play it a couple of times but
then they would right so aaron samson i
think it's there's a feature going up on
gamespot today aaron played
through
the game and then shows i think the the
branching path is at the end of the the
gameplay section before the tv show is
literally a binary choice and then they
play different uh um
scenes in the tv show part of it
uh but i'm not sure how much of the it's
the incidental stuff that i'm interested
in so the when you pick up the narrative
objects and like how much they
impact on the the story at large and
also the the the videos in between that
i'm not really
sure about it i mean this game isn't
heavy rain like right it's a linear
shooter right so there's only so much
they're actually going to be able to
mess around with it's not approaching
like until dawn or anything no nowhere
near that level of uh
branching fast i'm gonna murder two of
these guys with one time murder bubble
oops i missed that guy
oh yeah look he got shot over the top
that's pretty funny i like that
all right i'm gonna use my time dodge a
little bit let's see if i can pull it
off so you could a bit of a boom and
then
slow it down a bit
and i accidentally dumped off one of
these
time bubbles oh okay i thought that was
part of the time dodge or something i
wonder what that was
that was just me being a dumbass yeah
whoa
no that's not what you want to do bro
all right i tried to jump away and he
decided to jump up against the wall
is there anything i wonder if there's
something later on where you can almost
like just can you completely rewind
no i don't okay i won't say no because i
haven't unlocked all the parents
from what i've seen no okay there is no
british lady from overwatch
mechanic
in this game like tim from breed
there's no soulja boy talum will not be
playing this game
on his youtube channel am i all the way
back here really oh no i'm here okay
yeah so it's i mean you can see there
the game is pretty forgiving when it
comes to getting shot at but the way
i've been playing this game is
not the conservative
way i play games like i'm i'm sorry i
keep bringing it up and i'm playing a
lot of the division at the moment not
the way i play that where it's like you
hide behind cover and kill people
because otherwise they'll kill you like
this game is about killing people with
style right right so if you're not
jumping out there and throwing time
bubbles and doing dumbness then like
you're not playing this game right okay
that's what i think can't be too
conservative no cause look it's funny
look boom boom boom i'm gonna shoot that
guy over the top
where did that guy
look how much fun they are to shoot when
they have that stupid like light on
their head have you found that any of
the powers are pretty like easily
spammed
or is that kind of the point of the game
to really be overpowered yeah so it's a
game that like
after a while you they really start to
amp up the difficulty of some of the
bosses you come up against like there's
big cruiser dudes who
you know they they take
three shotgun blasts to kill at like
relatively close range and then you
start to fight
which is not which i think is in the
next chapter so we can't show it but
it's been in the uh gameplay they've
shown before
then there are people like you
people who can also
[ __ ] with time other time [ __ ]
and they'll get you because they've got
these cronon pack things on the backs of
their
on their uh hey what's up bro oh yeah
murderer pretty good
yeah they've got little
time backpacks that you can shoot and it
really messes them up which is pretty
funny
i don't think i don't think that'll come
up in this sadly but they're pretty cool
yes this is a good enemy variety stop it
don't be that guy
look at that what where's the school
like there's a lot yeah it's a pretty
well funded university somewhere in
like
fake town america it kind of it looks
like portland or seattle or something
okay it's like very pacific northwest
gotcha but it's called like bridgeport
or something okay i think it's
bridgeport look at this guy he also
kicked bodies that's actually a town
right near where i grew up bridgeport
yep it's in syracuse yeah right outside
syracuse bridgetown new york maybe it is
then who knows
yeah i'm gonna knock this tray over
injured myself because game physics
that explains the weird
time shifts going on back home
explains why i called up my mom
yesterday and it was 17 years ago and
she was like how are you calling me
you're only five years old where'd you
get a cell phone
where did you get a
what's a cell phone oh my god is this
the white house no it's not
yeah so i like i like messing around
these environments because they're
really well detailed that's one of the
things that's happened a lot in this
generation of consoles which doesn't
really come across when they're showing
trailers and when everyone's trying to
get hyped up about like video games are
rad and they look great and all that is
that the amount of detail in games now
is insane yeah like this place like the
divisions this place looks crazy too
also they have
stone crow
things everywhere uh i will also say
that this game does have a television
show
a la allen wake a la lords and ladies
from mac spain
you mean separate from the episodes yes
sorry yeah so says own in world time air
tv show exactly okay it has its own in
universe television show which sadly i
couldn't show you uh
the one that i found because it was
before the embargo place was
but i will say this
sam lake stars in it
okay
and it's pretty dumb that makes sense in
a sort of a mulder and scully type oh i
think alexa might have been talking
about that when she came in today yeah
okay
sounds
sounds goofy yeah it took it out it
looked it looked pretty dumb all right
so here's where here's where the time
platforming happens
okay here's where you got to take out
your
tim from braids cause look you gotta
jump across this
but ah
i don't have time for this he said it
again
he doesn't have time for this mike how
many times do they say that how many
times yeah
i don't know too many
time bubble
oh was it so is that lowering when you
jumped on it yeah it was because i'm so
fat okay
it's also poorly constructed whatever
those things are called yeah i imagine
construction workers just getting up top
and then it's just going back down
this cherry pick is busted lou why you
got to give us this piece of crap one
hey i don't know the guy who made it
it's got time powers
in a time widget seems fine with it i
don't know what's wrong with you
that guy up there
hands were
i haven't got time for this what the
hell is going on around here i don't
know you didn't do that i don't think he
thinks that he shot that guy with a
bullet somehow
if pete doesn't use uh
time is on my side for his lead i'll be
that's pretty good i'll be mad i mean
there's a whole there's a lot of them
there's a lot of options there the times
they are changing
that's pretty good yeah damn it no time
like the presents there you go
uh any any suggestions from the chat on
decks and leads or any questions yes
throw them at me anybody
look at that guy he looked right now you
don't notice me oh he did see me
but he's in a time bubble
boom
best part of the game
he stole it from max ma3
i'm gonna refill my gun and there's a
bunch of different guns it it feels like
alan awaken that and max payne in the
way that you are like constantly running
out of weapon for weapo sorry for ammo
for weapon twos you're picking up weapon
three so it sort of forced a little bit
of
diversity in terms of the weapons you
use but a lot of them are very similar
pistols are pretty good though actually
i'm going to pick up this heavy pistol
all right where am i going next i
probably should be going this way
for those asking there's no multiplayer
in this game no
single-player story-driven experience i
believe yes very much all these kind of
things like alan wake yeah we used to
call them video games
before everything had to have
multiplayer right
here we go the division like the long
division we keep talking about it hey
what's up guys
oh man oh slack
he could have just said shut up he got a
stop pistol with him it was a bit a bit
excessive
oh no funny had some sort of time bubble
from halo
i guess i was in time
and neither is this really it's just a
bubble it's a bubble shield
it's pretty handy especially when you're
getting wrecked
by a bunch of dudes
or time ladies i'm not sure if there are
time ladies
boom whoa that is a heavy pistol
yeah so you can i think you can turn off
the auto aim actually let me just have a
quick little look in here and just see
if we can
gameplay game sensitivity aim assist
disabled let's see
let's see how that one looks all right
oh look at this guy
yeah i mean that's significantly more
difficult okay
unless i make them yeah time stop
luckily you can control time
get this gone much better so how is that
explained
like how do they explain that x-ray
vision is that oh it's just time powers
you know yeah chronos you know
cronon
trigger
futons yeah something
god damn it
eat it
all right who's next
there's a lot of exploding barrels in
this world as well i'll say that right
now
slow down time oh damn it you went the
other side
that's such a that's one of the oldest
video game
tropes what the exploding barrels oh
yeah you go back to doom for that one
i wonder if that was the first game
that's exploding barrels
yeah
that's the earliest one i can think of
now
wait i killed all these people
oh that's a good one actually pick up
this assault rifle
get some more ammo for it
let's do some hot time bubble pan
explodings
this game looks pretty it does i wonder
if it looks good on the stream because
we're having compression man
compressions making every every game
look flat like so many good looking
games look awful on streams like far cry
primal looked
like a disaster on streams those
textures is this what 720p i was reading
yeah i saw the headline i mean who cares
like you don't notice i don't really
good yeah i don't
like the event this game has a lot of
incredible looking particle stuff
happening in it
like
in terms of the density of the game
world and in terms of
like visual effects there's a lot
happening so if that means that there's
less
less less pixels on screen then yeah
okay sure i don't know like i didn't
play this game and think it looked like
720 disaster
okay
so we'll have to see
all right all those guys are having mad
bands they're going to try and kill all
these guys
anyone else all right this guy's up here
get out
yeah so take off auto aim it does
make it significantly more challenging
which is probably a good thing
i mean not that much
time to die time to die
thank you
whoa don't do that danny don't do that
danny time bubble
so that deflects them or just slows them
down so you can escape uh deflection
okay
oh that's areas
look at that i'm just getting underneath
there
i mean i will say that the auto aim
assist if i was playing this on a pc
with mouse and keyboard would wouldn't
matter at all yeah so i'm kind of
looking forward to playing the sun on pc
mostly because of that mostly so i can
be a bit more accurate look at that is
that your go-to method for shooters
yeah i mean
like everything's like some games you
can get away with playing on a
controller no problem sure
like a loss so many games are made for
console as well but like in a game like
this where you're shooting in between
bars like i was there like that would
have been nice to be able to be a bit
more precise like max payne 3 is a good
actual use case for that max pay 3 when
you play on pc is like a different game
right because it's like a head it's a
headshot hunt then when you play on pc
sure
so a scrood was asking are there any
like rpg mechanics as far as upgrade
trees for powers that you've seen there
are there is an upgrade
i don't think i've unlocked it yet there
is an upgrade
tree for your powers i will see if if
one comes up before the end of this i'll
show it off if if there isn't then i'll
just explain it now which is
each of your powers so you know the ones
up on the right you've got the the time
bubble the
times
defense bubble the the jumping one and
then there's a couple of other ones that
come along as well each of those you can
upgrade
using you know the first upgrade takes
one point the next one takes four points
next one take eight points and those
points you find them within the game
world by using this time vision
situation
uh
and then
the game started telegraphs whenever
they were around and then you hit the
button and look for them i wasn't
finding that many like i was seeing
something like you're a fan i found one
once and it said you offend one of 13
like in this area i was like okay what
so i don't think i was picking them up
as fast as the game wanted me to when i
was when i was playing earlier but
whoa
dvorak 67 says the first game to feature
exploding barrels you have any other
guesses according to this user was not
doom really teenage mutant ninja turtles
on nes oh really yeah i guess it would
have been yeah like the beat of oh this
guy he wanna commander king
yeah his other finger aiden gillen
norton irish actor
who was also frank ketty in the wire he
was lord rathbone and shanghai knights
that was the first thing i ever saw
really yeah geez
wow time punch
time punched the [ __ ] out of me what
happened to you what are you doing only
what's necessary
it's turned up think about this you
don't know what's at stake i know
exactly what's at stake that's why i'm
here you believe you can stop what's
coming
i'm giving you one chance to change your
mind
this path it's already said it can't be
changed the past the future i've seen it
i've lived it
for 17 years
17 years so he's seven he's 17 years in
the come with me and we can see this
through what are you saying you're 17
years old hold on to your heart
burn with it now listen i built a device
i can stop this i can you can't this is
madness there's no harm in trying there
is that's why i can't risk you opposing
me will see this is cool it doesn't have
to win like this rewatching this it's
actually i'm understanding things better
because they've already they have a
history that we don't know about right
yeah okay
it took me years to come to terms with
what must be done so that's what i'm
looking forward to and that's what i'm
hoping pulls off in this game is that
the stories compelling because the
action's kind of it's fine it's like the
action's like
it's in the same way i feel like alan
wake was like nothing to really write
home about but it was it like
facilitated this interesting experience
you know
and i feel like if one of these games
comes around every six years then yeah
i'll play it you know yeah
uh oh oh oh
god everyone's getting hit in the face
with guns
dyke and that is the end of act one
all right which has this really
i love this
i can't skip this rayman intro that did
the same thing between each chapter
rayman legends that's a weird reference
but yeah that like the congo drums
so i think the end i can't talk about it
because it's under embargo but
you may have seen alexa tweeting about
something last week
that was in an embargo sheet
that we weren't allowed to show i think
next week we could show it one of the
musical selections for these end of acts
is pretty good i'll just say that end of
act one now you piqued my curiosity so
can we keep oh we can keep going okay
yeah
we're all out show now this [ __ ]
which is the television show oh
here we go kind of so this is the
this is going to be a cut scene
and then the tv show literally streams
my name is paul they're not on the disc
they stream so you have to go into an
app on the xbox no it does it in game
but it like literally has like a forward
rewind thing happening oh okay yeah
there are those who would question my
actions yeah
so all these side characters they get
fleshed out like this dude for instance
he gets fleshed out in the tv show quite
well vindication a testimony of how
things came to be the two of them do and
then there's a lot of characters that
you never see in the game or i haven't
seen in the game yet
which are in the tv show part as well is
that beth wilder again i think so i
think that's your name
because i've seen where this leads so
this bit here i'm not really sure how i
feel about these bits they're kind
they're interesting
but i'm not sure how much they impact
the game overall
but essentially what's gonna happen here
is all the student protesters there was
a big you know
essentially what looked like a massive
shootout at a university so they're
gonna have to figure out some way of
like
you know
covering it up right yeah so student
riots that's a good idea right
on the inside
could the tv show stream if you were
offline
i doubt it okay
yeah so in that way you probably need to
be online for a good point
so i'll find who's behind this this
isn't the tv episode this is like a
bookend yeah this is a cutscene you will
know the tv show when it comes up okay
and then and then we are going to be
streaming a tv
show i'm talking about mystery science
theater kind of thing
yeah sorry for trying not to talk over
these guys actually here sorry
further obstacles at the stage of the
player
so i'm literally playing
two
options force remove any loose ends
but if those witnesses disappear the
public will start asking questions all
clear sir potentially turn on monarch
alternatively i came out a broad pr
strategy get the city on our side
but that leaves us with the loose ends
precisely
the choice is yours but keep in mind
the men will view your decision as a
unified strategy moving forward company
doesn't play any women
so i can do one of two things we're
gonna leave it up to the the twitch chat
i can basically either
trick this girl into
recording a news post saying that
this was a terrorist attack done by
that guy who was ice man in x-men
or
i think i can just have them all
murdered
who is this
amy ferrero so it's up to you chad
your orders murder or pr or hardline is
what they say
pr or hardline so put in the twitch shot
pr if you want
us not to murder this girl
i'm really telegraphing which one i want
them to do
murder murder
murder
kill everyone
time murder murder murder there's one pr
there's one vr her son wants pr but i
think we're going to go for
i think we're going to have a little
murder time here so i haven't done the
murder one yet
because i didn't want to be a
cold-hearted son of a [ __ ] but what's
this is this it we had jack in custody
all right there's more but i was
starting to witness more delicious from
the
my powers grew stronger even as the
cronon syndrome worsened whoa
i could choose a path that would become
the actual future
so that's their story optional
reason the moment wouldn't end until i
made up my mind
junction impacts the junction power
reveals to your potential futures your
decision at each juncture point will
steer the stories of both game and
live-action show choose wisely
hardline also known as time murder
oh this is a rim
any potential threats to our plan need
to be erased
monarch would take a hard-line approach
crush all obstacles eliminate all
witnesses it would be harsh
but i had made hard choices for the
greater good before she's gonna shoot
her
her
handcuffs
this is messed up man
oh wow so maybe it is changing parts of
his story too riverport
would turn against us he's on the
neograph there
protest at my school uh last year
nothing like no molotov's involved
though
all right so i oh so i can i can have a
look at the pr one as well actually i
think
oh okay let's show pr initialize a pr
campaign
i
and that violence was because of jack
joyce monarch would take a pr friendly
approach and manipulate the public into
siding with us
our lies would give us control so these
happen at the end of every chapter i
believe i think the game is like six
five or six chapters i think i don't
know okay
it smells like schrodinger's cat stuff
yeah we'd use the media to expose then
hunt for jack
i uploaded all the files that's really
cool because this has actually happened
in my version of the game so
eyewitnesses would be out there
and jack would learn our secrets so it's
weird because of the whole time thing
they're able to okay i'm gonna murder
them but anyway but because of the whole
time thing the game is it is kind of
interesting actually playing through a
second time because
it's telegraphing a lot of the stuff
that i've seen
and they're sort of referencing stuff
that i didn't pick up on the first time
around
concur and the others to the ground zero
operation yeah
oh make it quick
painless
no
wait okay you know what
now i'm wondering if they're if they do
actually murder because
where i found her i think was in a very
similar situation to where they just
referenced okay so maybe they just get
around it i don't know there's no other
way out going through
sadly we can't show you because it's
under embargoes
oh
this is the time machine that you saw we
weren't allowed to show earlier okay
i use my power to guide us
to decide how to best prepare for the
inevitable end of time and this is when
he comes out of the machine and it's
game of thrones time that gives the
chosen few a chance to survive
i've seen the end of time
so he goes to the end of time
and comes back
oh no
28 of the community went for
the
time murder
choice nobody none of my friends none of
my friends agreed on my choice
who are my friends who played this game
king crowd has played it
there you go
wanna watch tv show yeah let's watch the
tv show oh jeez the whole like
dvd interface yeah i know it'll don't
worry it'll it'll get better quality in
a second episode one monarch solutions
this is straight up a tv show i think
it's about 20 minutes long
let's time it okay
and we will try not to talk over it too
much time's up time's up get it
oh that's hurt hey what's up
what do you want
i want the wire to be rebooted
so this is a different scene so when i
picked pr slightly it's the same scene
but they're saying different things
i'm going to stand i'm going to leave
and the woman
is going to shoot you in the head
no beating around no
[ __ ] you whoa
it's a family stream lady
that's some good fake crying
shooter
he's gonna shoot her
wait
oh wow all right
that didn't happen when you no
no i played a significant part of the
game with that girl oh actually
they just like shot two scenes yeah they
just
okay
yeah so in my version of chapter two
like i was literally i played a good
like 20 minutes of the game with her
character so that's actually really
interesting
huh okay
oh what happened there see those guys
they just time walked
that's that's handy
it's handy bonus i guess your commute to
work if you work for a monarch is like
three seconds left i saw the cameraman
didn't want to like dodge the shot they
just warped behind him yeah
eye drops
so those eye drops are i think they're
full of cronon particles okay
so for some reason some of the people in
this world are like sick
so they have to take the
the cronon
medicine
wait you're kidding right no oh okay
they're like time sick or something i
don't know
their bodies don't adjust while they're
warping through time you just need to
find him
one cut is working on a location
what is it
what
something's wrong
yeah you just murdered a girl
university that's how we operate
it was sloppy
have all your operations going smoothly
not as smooth as my hair sir
you would know anything about that baldy
i'm sure your wife misses baldi
so this is pretty well shot right look
at him there on his windows phone
he's got his corporate logo beautiful he
does windows baby in show advertising
look at this stuff
like they they did not pull back on the
budget when they made this stuff
so this guy the chris pine knockoff is
the kind of goofy hacker character all
servers are on a different platform
knock off that kind of right you need
two-way access resemblance
weaknesses a beard oh we have huh
where what weaknesses you said shut the
[ __ ] up bernard
jesus identify as a client who had
previous so there are things that happen
in this scene firewall and assuming all
these ports are just left or in this in
these protocol numbers scenes which may
differ slightly based on actions that
you've done
so come on for whatever reason this
whole gag about the coffee cup where he
put the coffee cup didn't happen this
time i'm not sure why
okay
and
butterfly effect yeah
something like that computers
headquarters i mean now i could hijack
police scanners yeah so this guy's
basically just watch dogging the game
what the [ __ ] is that oh he did do it
what is that oh he did do it sorry
coffee
yeah i know but aaron told me there was
something he did where the coffee cup
the coffee cup thing didn't know what it
is
coaster yeah do they have these in idaho
i will whatever
some state with an eye you tell me
what's next brenner i don't know i know
you don't know and that makes me sad for
you all we do now we draft an email
basically letting him know that monarch
is offering their private security
forces which of course he's gonna take
because at this point without him
knowing we've tied both his hands behind
his back when he wasn't looking
and that brenner is how you take river
port
under monarch control
it's a watchdog
it's a oh picture he's got
just the most ominous looking portrait
ever yep mr hatch perfect timing
where are we with joyce joyce yeah i uh
i've got the cameras i just need to find
a local keep an eye on it and when you
find him contact book directly i think
we have a traitor in our midst a traitor
somebody stole my eye drops
my time eye drops but i'll let you go mr
hatch thank you
that's pretty good is that martin hatch
get the [ __ ] out of my office
get the [ __ ] out of my office
this guy's the worst manager ever
it's like mark wahlberg's character from
the departed
get the [ __ ] out of my office
maybe
this guy's going home
after his day on the job murdering
students
well that was a weird day at work got
him a nice car
yeah
but he has to get dressed into like
civvy clothes or something
because he because that coat was so like
murderous i know yeah i look too much
like i work for a murder place that'd be
really funny if the shirt is thrown had
blood all over the back that he had no
idea about
this sweet car
hot day on the construction site today
cherry picker wasn't working no
hey what's up
why are you sitting ominously on the bed
for me all day
aren't you cold
these things have been really bad at
work
isn't this weird that this is just
happening in between chapters of a video
game
like isn't it kind of amazing yeah this
is an actual
like branching off onto this family
strife
okay we're six minutes in right now it's
a six minute long cutscene these big
fray bear paws
way too big for your buddy
what a strange creature
what's she doing
she's just hanging out at home that's
what
in video game land that's what wives do
they just sit in bed waiting for
their murder husbands to return crying
until he gets back
with makeup on more than any guild
manager in the history of field
management field manager
you wouldn't believe how many students i
either murdered today love
maybe you haven't been home four more
than last week
the only way to finish this scene is to
have sex that's the only
that's it cameron's not gonna
oh she's pregnant that's going to cause
moral decisions
they're good okay okay the camera is not
going to leave until we have sex i know
right that's exactly yeah the
cameraman's gonna stay here until
there's a
something happens we have to have a
fight
somebody has to have a shower or like
say all right i'll make breakfast
or they have to have sex that's the only
yeah that's how i felt that's how
no one's looked like knowingly in the
mirror themselves yet
yes
that is the time video game they look at
themselves in the past
right i don't think i've ever
been kissing
my wife
and a phone rings from work
but that happens all the time in tv yeah
it's always just that buzzkill i just
have mine set to silence
does anyone have ringtones anymore i
don't
yeah
burke got a lead on joyce oh he was on
speaker i was like how was he calling
him
wilkins
inside ground zero perimeter
sending you the coordinates now
creepiest way to turn a corner ever
i gotta go
i haven't done murdering people today
she just pulls like an rpg out of the
pantry i'll be home soon
as well
time
stuff
i mean isn't this like shockingly well
produced for yeah
like a tv show for a video game tv show
look at this
so like i said the action isn't like
anything to write home about at all
but it's just it's wrapped up in this
package that's just
so unique and kind of like interesting
that it's been compelling me to keep
playing
but i'm not sure how how long that trick
lasts you know what i mean like
i guess we'll have to wait and find out
this game's on there for a couple of
weeks our review is not going to be out
for a couple of weeks
seattle right looks a little bit someone
someone had mentioned i'm not sure how
sure they were that it's like maine oh
really east coast like northeastern
pacific northwest and northeastern can
look pretty similar um at least where
i'm from because of the rain
yeah she's missing she got shot in the
head i was gonna say the guy in her
right did it
there's been a development
jack yeah he was at the beginning of
darkness
tonight on the island oh yeah
he'll be there
and he'll want revenge i need him
stopped now i think our focus may be
somewhat misguided here what's your next
plan crash this plane
traitor you shouldn't take it so lightly
joyce got lucky he escaped he's gone
he wouldn't be foolish enough to come
back our only vulnerability is within
paul you should see that telling me what
i've already seen you're not thinking
clearly
you need your treatment you haven't you
see treatments
you've been the face of monarch for
all these years martin
this is still my ship i'll take my time
medicine when i want to i simply don't
want to see you go down with it
i'll go down on you wait
i came out
wrong where are you going i'm taking
some paid time off
every single tv in the world is on this
channel
i mean i guess it would be
every wall of this building has got the
logo the corporate logo this guy doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's got his like hash
browns he's fine for the day
sweet neck tattoo finding those
yeah this cutscene's not over by the way
we're still going
we got we got
12 and a half minutes on the clock
just in time for lunch who's she going
to meet up but you got two of them she's
just really hungry
chris pine's even hungrier
you wish i was right
hey you don't have security clearance
being here security clearance access
granted i thought you might have been up
all night so
you didn't get the running kind did you
no it shouldn't be
not the runny kind
there's coasters for your heels
oh man yeah different girls different
rules for for the love interest
terminated
you're fired
so what the what's the four one one what
the hell is going on no one says that
yeah
okay at least
enough
that it's it's like not really taking
itself too seriously right
you need that care if it's like crazy
like this you need that character that's
just as
amused as the audience yeah
which they've always kind of managed
like it's the weird thing about remedy
games where are you gonna go
like they're they're kind of serious but
then they're also not at all like max
payne had like lords and ladies while
also being this like ridiculous noir
melodrama right yeah alan wake was this
like super serious like writer okay
family drama situation but then it was
just a hokey dumb sci-fi okay jaunt as
well you know yeah this game is doing it
in a different way it's like i don't
know i don't know maybe uh
i don't know i haven't played enough to
figure out exactly but it's kind of nice
it feels very surprising to get back to
my desk whereas in those throwbacks to
like older genres this feels like
i mean it literally has a streaming tv
show in it like that's pretty 2016.
buddy he's not lacking in originality
he's in the friend zone he's not happy
about it
i promised i promised it was a full tv
show between everyone
there's always an ominous wharf
dwarf a wharf yeah yeah okay
name the cheapest places to shoot movies
wharfs at the field behind your uncle's
house
uh a school yeah that you broke into and
the teachers aren't there and
uh
just the sidewalk yeah or like in a
house or in the house
every horror movie ever
all the cheap ones that do loads of
money are just in houses
and then wharfs abandoned buildings liam
this isn't what it looks like
[ __ ] beth
i really didn't want it to be you
you need to listen to me she's the
traitor step away from the van watch
this this is pretty good this is pretty
good step away right now
drop the gun shoot next to a van 30 tons
of nitroglycerin
had better reflexes than you're a
marksman for [ __ ]
no
no
he's gone
do you see what's happening
the starters more and more
what is what's going on time is breaking
down
the end is coming and joyce could be the
key to avoid the end the end of one
that's the end of what
time the time
of life as we know it the entire
universe your baby will never know
somehow monarch has been preparing for
it the beauty of riverboarding you knew
it was coming
there's this thing
it's called a lifeboat protocol and it
can save us at least some of us time
life vote
someone pointed out a massachusetts
license plate oh really yeah okay
joyce just took down half by men you
think maybe he had some help we're
unarmed oh that's really well done now i
understand why that happened
oh that's this is cool if they take me
into them
together yeah actually i'm i'm really
enjoying watching this the second time
around because
that's actually super smart what that
guy just said
because you obviously played this
section as joyce right yeah shut up
yeah
they don't even need time no
they don't need time murder
this is regular murder
you have to be a time wizard to work
here but it sure helps
this lifeboat protocol
what is it i don't know
but dr kim was at the center of it dr
kim
people are writing the screenplay in the
chat it's kind of funny oh really
time to eat your sandwich
while you're still on the clock
this guy's going through a lot of cctv
i wonder how many hipsters you've seen
jerking off in alleyways
wait pause that zoom in refract it
oh no the running kind
heels on my desk
right runny eggs
who needs friends hey who needs enemies
enhanced enhanced
i said lumburg
we're 18 minutes into this
is gonna love this there's more to go
three hours after fracture in time
he's using windows 10 there as well
which i like
october 9th microsoft game studio is
really doing a solid one
did you say october 9th is that what it
was
i tried to remember a day back the
future took place on october 26th though
i wonder if there's any parallels there
gotcha i'm looking too deep
oh he's got a usb with the evidence on
it
could just do a simple time steal again
he'd be like oh he's gone already
charlie
oh
i need a favor
yeah
could we talk somewhere in private
uh you're really rather not in your
office it'll be good
it'll be really quick
yeah
no he's got the evidence of that guy
beating up monarch people yeah
the mole is the girl
right
right
out there i mean sorry we have been
talking over this entire thing here to
get access to it can you help me out
and this is only the start of the game
folks don't worry about spoilers
thank you
yeah we're gonna wrap this up after the
end of this super short cutscene you
know it's really funny that you say that
that lead on joyce was no good because
here we go oh
it sure looks like he was there and that
other guy kind of looks like you but
that's weird because you work for
monarch and that guy clearly he clearly
does not work for monarchs
hey
wait stop killing me because i just put
a high security alert out on your ass
you got about 20 seconds you're bluffing
hey you're welcome to stick around try
to find out you know what i'm gonna do
to you have a pretty good idea what
monarch's gonna do to you
i'm about 15
14
13
12
11. time man
what are your time powers
we need all points converged on liam
burke he just has like
like a walkie-talkie there broadband
radio
get your flu shots i love all the ink
the random
they're talking about food trucks
earlier on the
tanoi
here we go pass right by him
ah
dudes owed me money
i wonder if that's like the same
takedown they use in every movie when
there's two people that's like [ __ ]
idiots who's right yeah
you always have to like point one dude
with the other guy
yeah they just like that's how they
teach stunt actors
whoa this guy just unloaded some random
shots in a public office
he's in the building
that guy's a kooky character
what is wrong with that stairwell i know
right it's like the most inefficiently
made stairwell ever also why didn't all
these security guards have guns
south parking structure fourth floor i
mean they've literally covered head to
toe and bulletproof
why would they not have guns
trying to get my sweet car
and i think this was this was the moment
where i realized okay they've put money
into this because this is actually like
a
relatively decent
chick uh car chase scene
that's that actually takes place on like
streets
look at this nonsense
get out of there ben affleck
oh
microsoft's gonna have to pay for that
a lot of nissans in this
out of here
nice bit of understeer
gotta smash at least one of those
come on
this reminds me of the intro for grand
theft auto 2.
okay he said he's south on
if you're just joining us on this stream
this is quantum break the video game
believe it or not
we played the game for about i don't
know
35 minutes we're 25 minutes 23 minutes
into
the first of the tv show episodes which
occur after each act in the game
i mean this is pretty like high budget
right like
it's not a movie but
it's not like
they hit
me
they passed that same white volkswagen
about five times now
it could be a different one though a lot
of people are driving white volkswagen
they're a super popular car right now
yeah that
look at this
pete brown had mentioned
he had the same uh
notion
of volkswagens no he he
came in one day like i think they passed
the same car like six times
look i love this shot here so much it's
like 12 different cameras it's so well
done it's like you know it's the
crescendo of a scene because it's like
there's like a camera car and then
inside and then quick as hell this guy
here and then front and look this is so
many camera angles
use them all up
don't do it you've got a child you've
got a child
time to think about your family
boom
that's that i think that's that
end of episode one
of how many did you say i i don't i
don't want to say i don't expect it i
think it might be like in the five six
okay
and that's it that is our now playing of
quantum break the latest game from
remedy creators of the max payne
franchise max playing one and two they
didn't make three that was rockstar they
did make alan wake which is a fantastic
game this video game is out on the 5th
of april 2016 which is like two weeks
away yeah invisible i don't know yeah so
we this is the first amount of stuff the
world show uh next week we have another
embargo for the second chapter so if you
want in on that make sure to follow
myself and mic on twitter and we will
tweet that one out and get back in here
uh yeah and that's that's quantum break
coming out on pc and xbox one in a
couple of weeks what did what what were
your impressions of that i was with you
the tv show seemed
like very high budget and like high
production value like more than i was
expecting i think i was just like i said
expecting these like full motion video
kind of cut scenes yeah i didn't know
you it would be like something you could
actually like rewind and fast forward
and whatnot um but the game seems
promising i'd have to i'd have to play
more of i've
what you played is what i've seen of it
aside from trailers and whatnot so i'm
i'm looking forward to seeing more
powers and how they all kind of like
weave together in the uh combat because
that could that's the draw for me yeah
that's the we can obviously show but
that's that's kind of what i've
experienced later is that you do get
more powers but
from what i've played it's not getting
into it hasn't yet kicked into like this
is a super engrossing action experience
it's like
enjoyable but sort of
nothing
crazy to write home about but it's the
for me personally the overall package is
what's been drawing me back and like i
don't watch television i don't watch
i watch like netflix series is every
once in a while like house of cards and
stuff like that but i don't like watch
like sci-fi or like you know daredevil
or any of these like you know mid-budget
tv shows ever so i'm not into that but i
think my expectations were kind of so
like
in the middle for what the video stuff
might be that i was actually like super
pleasantly surprised
by how it all works out i'm actually the
one thing that's taken me back a little
bit about this now playing is how much
how they basically just killed off a
character that i spent a lot of time
with later in the game
that's interesting that's actually
pretty cool and if this is what happened
i mean
hopefully they do that after every
chapter and then there's like maybe
maybe like kill off a character every
chapter hopefully they do something
right
that makes it that makes a little bit
different so i'm interested in that i'm
very interested now actually at this
stage yeah because that's interesting
because i like we've been playing some
open world games like our this year in
like open-ended strategy games i kind of
want something that's just going to pull
me through on a string but the fact that
you know you can have these branching
story lines that completely change up
the tv show and the game seems pretty
appealing like maybe i don't know about
replay value but like as far as just
having these stories you come in and
like talk to other people who had a
completely different experience
looking forward to it so i guess we'll
have to we'll have to wait and see
that's all we can show today sadly thank
you so much for tuning in thank you so
much mike mccarty thanks for playing for
joining me today no problem our review
will be live in like a couple of weeks
like i i i don't know exactly where the
embargo is it's probably around the
release date april 5th uh but we'll be
back
next week on gamespot right here on
twitch.tv spot on gamespot.com to play
more quantum breaks so make sure you hit
that follow button subscribe
if you want to watch some more of that
uh the week of video games just started
there's gonna be loads more stuff up on
the site uh so until
then have a great week and will see you
later on right here on gamespot
bye time friends
time for us to time for us to
get out of here
we're out of time we're out of time
we're outside
we're outside goodbye
you